alex servant l'armée prenne ce risque
mais pendant ces permissions en europe
lui ni sa femme ni son fils quand il
était là je ne pouvais pas travailler
calmement sachant que aussi été sous les
bombes donc la décision a été prise de
les faire quitter le pays tous les jours
on se passe
ma femme est actuellement à champigny en
france elle a toujours rêvé de voir
paris son rêve s'est réalisé mais bien
sûr on aurait préféré que les
circonstances sont différentes mais
quand tout sera fini après notre
victoire on vivra tous ensemble là bas à
champigny ça a l'air bien ça donne de
gros lot
tetiana elle est partie en république
tchèque après l'invasion mais à peine de
retour à cram à tort ce qu elle a
découvert que son mari s'était enrôlé
dans l'armée
il m'a dit que moi aussi je devais
défendre mon pays
qu'est ce que je dirai à mon fils quand
ils me demandera ce que j'ai fait
pendant la guerre j'ai pleuré bien sûr
je ne voulais pas qu'il parte sa mère
aussi a pleuré parce qu il y a deux
façons de voir les choses c'est
magnifique qu'ils défendent notre pays
mais je suis là moi il ya notre fils
aussi on ne peut pas vivre sans lui
tetiana a fini par accepter la décision
de son mari mais n'a pu rester les bras
croisés elle a lancé une cagnotte sur
instagram pour lui acheter un meilleur
et classer ses photos
l'armée fournit tout mais je pense qu'il
se sentira plus en sécurité avec les
meilleures protections possibles
il n'a et nicolas était en lune de miel
à l'étranger quand la guerre a éclaté
ils sont revenus conscient du risque
pour lui de devoir rejoindre les rangs
de l'armée
le moment n'est pas encore venu pour moi
il ya des vagues d'une organisation
successives
mais quoi qu'il arrive je crois que je
dois rester ici en ukraine le couple n'a
toutefois pas l'intention de s'éterniser
akram à tort c'que ça peut vraiment
faire ici
je ne dors que la moitié des nuits
ce qui les empêche pour l'instant de
partir c'est cette voiture
il n'y a pas de problème sur l'autoroute
mais dès qu'on est dans le trafic comme
un chat pointe elle surchauffe on va la
faire réparer après on s'ennuiera
quelque part
quelque part ils ne savent pas où mais
au moins ils sont ensemble pour
l'instant